cette affaire de sorcellerie au sein des
marseillais est devenu un véritable
tribunal populaire
hier soir c'est magali berda qui se
présentait de nouveau à la barre pour se
justifier des accusations sur la fuite
des vidéos concernant carla moreau et
devront se séparer de miles a rapidement
et instantanément et que car l'art de
vienne et vienne à tout jamais la
première des candidates de télé vidéo
révélée diffusé par le blogueur marc
platt à magali a affirmé avoir été mise
au courant mais avoir repoussé leur
diffusion afin de préserver car là on
lui a demandé s'il te plaît à temps
qu'on m'ait carla à l'abri avec sa
famille qu elles sont entourées par
qu'elle était seul au moment où on
n'était que des fans pourtant certains
internautes relève encore des
incohérences dans ce discours notamment
sur le fameux déroulé de la journée où
les vidéos ont été diffusées et sur les
déclarations que magali avait eu lors de
son précédent passage sûreté pmp magali
barda nous prend vraiment pour des
neuneus
pourquoi ne pas avoir parlé du racket
dès la sortie des vidéos pour mac date a
vu qu'à nous dit ce soir qu'elle savait
depuis un an
ça aurait laissé beaucoup moins de place
aux critiques sur carla alors magali
vous at elle convaincu hier soir alors
vous at elle convaincu hier soir et il
ya des noms bars et magali berda bien
sûr c'est convaincu un scandale ni moins
alors qui alors vous avez été convaincu
par magali bertin web ça m'énerve que
magali tout le monde lui tombe dessus
alors quand va-t-elle à rien avant avec
cette affaire elle fait que défendre car
l'acquis et c'est sa candidate c'est son
agent g à monsieur tout le monde aime
bien lui tomber dessus à magali parce
que c'est une femme qui réussit et qui
marche très bien qui a beaucoup de
succès dans le business je ne comprends
pas qu'ils aient saisi leur sénat
convaincu et c'est pas sûr elle qu'on
devrait tomber c'est plus sur les
protagonistes de cette affaire elle elle
fait que défendre ses candidats maxime
ganic est convaincue elle m'a bien
convaincu parce qu'elle s'habille messer
france à j'ai l'impression et magali
depuis quelques années une médiatisation
c'est devenu une prophétie parce que
l'animal chez les réalités l'image qui
est pas très très apprécié par une
certaine catégorie et des gens sur les
réseaux sociaux mais elle est venue elle
m'a convaincue elle est venue avec des
arguments surtout et des preuves avec
les vidéos elles étaient pas obligés de
le faire hein on est d'accord
donc elle est de bonne foi et je te
crois vraiment qu'on voit ça a coûté
satisfait pas les bananes hommes non moi
je bosse me pose toujours la question à
qui profite le crime
en tout cas pas un maghrébin dit
toujours pas mal
ça entache sa candidate ça entache sa
boîte et donc tu vois pas quelqu'un qui
est à la tête d'une énorme boîte avoir
envie de faire un bad buzz sur cette
boîte
je sais bien que maintenant on dit que
il faut du buzz peu importe qu'il soit
mauvais au bon mais là il est tellement
mauvais que je vois pas l'intérêt de
magali d'aller là dedans et de et de
nous balader au contraire je pense que
malheureusement c'est une victime
collatérale or elle essaye de protéger
comme elles peu sa cliente mais voilà on
fait tous les we un prof rallye dont
bien entendu c'est surtout que c'est son
métier à ma gagner c'est très bien ce
qu'a fait et en recevant les
informations elle savait très bien que
ça va faire un bad buzz la normale avait
aucun intérêt à diffuser ça et puis je
pense surtout qu'elle est complètement
dépassés autant que tout le monde en
fait un finalement c'est un boulot
énorme pour elles de s'occuper de carla
de passer sur les plateaux tv notamment
sûreté pmp mais aussi dans d'autres
articles d'autres interviews pour
essayer de défendre car là de défendre
toute cette histoire et je pense que
c'est épuisant en force alors tu
leverdez cyril vous êtes un homme
honnête et j'ai une question à vous
poser est ce qu'un énorme mensonge par
omission est un mensonge
oui ou non mentir par omission et ce
menti et 4h les conséquences de la crise
et mon tir magali berda a menti un
énorme mensonge ça c'est mon ami à nous
a trahis
je vais vous expliquer ce qui s'est
passé elle à cacher quelque chose de fou
magali magali a des liens familiaux
magali a des liens familiaux avec kevin
magali a des liens familiaux avec
qu'evian voilà c'est vrai et selon mes
informations je vais laisser répondre
selon mes informations à l'intérieur de
la famille de kevin il y a quelques
problèmes et on m'a dit elle va répondre
éventuellement qu'éventuellement elle
aurait pu laisser fuiter ces
informations parce qu'elle est au fond
d'elle-même en guerre avec kevin
catégorie tv
alors alors les liens familiaux c'est
vrai que kevin lavoix je l'adorais oui
mais on aimait bien senti alors
l'habilité c'est que c'est vrai et je
m'en suis c'est le cousin de mon chéri
voilà
si ça rate mais c'est la vérité je peux
pas revenir
non mais ils sont ils sont réunis voilà
et chats mais kevin je te dire la vérité
quand j'ai quand j'ai eu connaissance de
cette histoire
la première personne que j'ai voulu
protéger c'était kevin parce que comme
je lé d'hier on a tous eu des doutes et
kevin c'est quelqu'un que j'aime
profondément c'est mon petit frère et ça
je le dis devant tout le monde et je
m'en fous de ce qu'on pense c'est mon
petit frère quoiqu'il mais ça n'empêche
pas que l'histoire est bien lui c'est
une victime de tout ça il s'est battu
pour sa femme il s'est battu pour sa
fille on peut pas lui enlever ça donc ça
n'a rien à voir que ce soit le cousin de
mon chéri ou pas je vois pas le rapport
ça c'est encore du fantasme des gens
pour faire parler pour aller content
parce que c'est plus intéressant d'aller
contre et c'est mieux d'aller contre
politiquement parlant c'est mieux
d'aller contre et on le sait gilles
c'est tout mais oui c'est mon coude
c'est le cousin de mon mari je laime
c'est mon ami c'est mon petit frère oui
voilà
dessine moi c'est un peu une histoire
qui me dépasse et qui m'intéresse pas
spécialement mais mais mais ce qui me
dérange ce sens dérangeant mais c'est là
roger qui t'intéresse c'est bon
ce qui me dérange c'est que toutes les
personnes ont un peu les mêmes éléments
de langage le fameux quoi qu'il arrive
la vidéo devait sortir c'est comme si tu
réunit des personnes celui qu'on m'a dit
on va se dire ça ok on dit ça on dit ça
toi tu dit ça on dit ça c'est juste ça
donc je me dis qu'il ya peut-être
quelque chose d'autre ce fameux truc au
dessus qu'on comprend pas qui est un peu
gênant
l'histoire est bien ce que dit et c'est
ce qui est revenue aussi un peu sur les
réseaux c'est que vous aviez c'est vrai
que d'être géraldine avait dit un jour
il parlait d'un discours bien rodé c'est
ce que disait géraldine qu'est ce que
vous répondez à sa magic en fait quand
il s'est passé quand il ya des faits qui
se sont passés
je vois pas l'utilité d'aller inventer
d'autres faits en fait j'ai donné ma
version
ces personnes ont donné leur version et
un moment donné où je peux pas aller
inventer des choses pour faire plaisir
au public pour ajouter des commentaires
des arguments pour essayer de convaincre
alors je vais rajouter ça ça bah non je
dis la vérité
c'est comme ça je l'éprouvé maintenant
après comme je l'étais hier soir ce
qu'il veut il croire il croit à ce qu'il
veut pas y croire il y croit pas c'est
c'est vrai que cette histoire elle est
complètement surréaliste et j'étais la
première à dire parce que moi aussi ça
m'a dépassé voilà et c'est tout c'est
pour revenir à ta leur attention j'ai
beaucoup parlé de cabine mais j'ai aussi
pensé à carla et j'ai pensé aussi aux
marseillais
parce que ça a affecté tout le monde
donc et ces gens là c'est ma famille et
moi ça fait cinq ans que je travaille
avec eux je les ai au quotidien on se
fait attaquer tout le temps en
permanence on est tout le temps à
attaquer quoi qu'on fasse c'est bien ou
c'est pas bien il ya un lynchage
aujourd'hui médiatique sur les candidats
de télé réalité et ça on peut pas dire
le contraire
pourquoi parce que c'est comme tu l'as
dit c'est une mauvaise image c'est comme
ça il se montre y est c'est comme ça
mais moi je suis à côté d'eux c'est mon
métier c'est mon travail
et en plus c'est ma famille donc après
official a passé la dernière partie de
touche comme d'ailleurs tout cas bien un
truc à terre il a appuyé sur un bouton
l'avait déjà fait pour la dgd on a des
jeunes nicolas pernikoff haut niveau
alors non elle m'a presque convaincus
eux c'est pas forcément mon métier au
quotidien mais il ya des petites
incohérences d'abord la première
incohérence et danané caisse y être en
contact avec vous qu'a voulu rendre
après il faut bien placé pardon et la
voyante voilà que donkey la voyance
technologie extrêmement calme et qui
nous a dit qu'il y avait quelque chose
qui nous échappait au dessus assez
attention à la façon c'est bien
au-dessus j'attends une réponse parce
que puisqu'il est manqué par être obligé
puisqu'elle l'a dit sur le plateau de
répondre à monsieur en effet au-dessus
s'arrête on fait normal après l'été donc
en contact direct avec vous puisque en
paix c'est faux non mais dans une télé
réalité alors que l'émetteur instagram
tout ça non mais elle est rentrée au
québec l échange avec vous non et pas
répondu vous avez pas répondu pas
qualifié pressé de rentrer en contact
avec mon prénom après ce que disent les
gens si je te dis c'est qu'il ya tous
les influenceurs de chez vous qui ont
fait beaucoup à bouquin à certains ayant
là il y en a quand vous allez sur son
instagram et je tiens vraiment à dire ça
c'est bizarre parce que sur son
instagram ya des influenceurs
effectivement de chez moi la d1 fientes
surdosage après il ya un point qui me
dérange c'est pourquoi pas c'est parce
marque blata pour faire diffuser cette
vidéo c'est cemac datacard voir sur les
vidéos
carole et c'est pourquoi il a reculé il
a reçu les vidéos se fait un problème
mais ça c'est bon mais ça c'est la
question justement qu'on se pose tous et
c'est la question de l' enquête parce
que carla a déposé aussi une plainte par
rapport à ça donc à 10 je savais pas oui
elle a déposé une plainte pour je sais
plus le terme exact et six mois parce
que moi c'est pas morte elle aussi
non le souhaitent de sortir dé diffuser
voilà des vides un corbeau y va mégane
mais on est là dedans mais lui il est il
est éveillé pas rester anonyme marcoule
atteint non il est pas resté anonyme et
autres on sait les souris lui a donné
quoi benjamin castaldi alors moi je vais
vous dire je connais bien magali et
c'est juste parce que tu la connais bien
que je connais son engagement auprès de
ces influenceurs que je pense
qu'effectivement il ya des choses qui la
dépasse et je pense qu'elle est sincère
dans puisqu'elle faisait d'hier mais je
fais absolument convaincu que quand on
écoute les uns et les autres je pense
qu'il ya vraiment d'autres éléments que
je n'ai pas j'en viens voilà on en parle
mais je l'aimé pas mais je sais une
chose c'est qu'elle est sincère gkd
quant à lui dit qu'elle est proche de
ses seins de ses candidats influence
dans cette vérité avant alors que ça et
qu'on sait les processus de la maison
elle dormait fin bref c'était une vraie
histoire de la dignité
mais je pense malheureusement que dans
cette histoire là ta gentillesse et ton
temps ton sort de victimes en deux tons
agences et je pense que malheureusement
tué dépassé par quelque chose qu'on ne
connaît pas encore mais qu'on va pas
tarder à connaître
oui mais c'est ce que j'ai dit depuis le
début ça laisse maintenant la justice
voilà ça y est je pense qu'à un moment
donné il faut aussi passer à autre chose
parce que c'est vrai que c'est épuisant
pour tout seul et que maintenant ben
voilà mais ça n'empêche pas que moi je
suis là pour mes candidats quels qu'ils
soient en difficulté à 18 heures voilà
qu'on verra on sera encore là la suite
de cette affaire très vite on n'espère
pas là et on saura qui a menti et qui
n'a pas menti bien sûr où le dira dans
cette émission
quoi qu'il arrive